the american drug regulator the fda has
approved the biotech fisa coronavirus
vaccine as the u.s readies itself to
introduce
mass immunization the vaccine was shown
to be
95 effective in preventing covid19 in a
late stage
trial healthcare workers and elderly
people in long-term care are expected to
be the first recipients
the vaccine gives cause for hope amid
these struggles with
soaring infection rates and covid
fatalities
president donald trump announced the
decision in a video released
late on friday he neglected however to
mention biontech the
german company that played a key role in
developing the vaccine
really good news today our nation has
achieved a medical
miracle we have delivered a safe and
effective vaccine in just
nine months it's a turning point for the
country with the highest coronavirus
death toll in the world
and counting clinics are preparing to
deliver the biontech pfizer shot and
begin the largest vaccination campaign
in u.s history healthcare workers and
elderly people in care homes are
expected to receive the first
doses but now that the vaccine is on its
way
will most americans take it
i think it's kind of your civic duty to
get vaccinated
and i don't see any issues with doing it
as long as it's safe
it's a way to depopulate the world
that's the agenda behind the vaccines
sorry i'm not interested in i will never
take it over my dead body
if that is the first step to kind of let
things open up then
i want to take that step to basically go
out and have normal times again
normal safe times some states are
planning to begin vaccinating as early
as monday
but the shot comes with complex
distribution challenges
it has to be shipped and stored at ultra
low temperatures
and countries are competing for limited
supplies
we are dealing with the question how to
produce more doses and this is a scaling
up
question and we are we are
in intensive intensive planning
procedures with
two colleagues from pfizer and ask the
question what can we do in europe what
can be done
in the united states how can we activate
earlier sites u.s health officials say
they will have enough doses to vaccinate
every american who wants to be by the
middle of next year
europe is set to make its own decision
on the biotech pfizer shot later this
month
in what could be the beginning of the
end of the global pandemic well joining
me now is dr peter chinhong he's an
infectious disease specialist at the
university of california
san francisco good to have you with us
doctor the fda was under real pressure
from the white house to
hurry up and approve emergency use of
the biotech fisa vaccine
should we be concerned about overt
political influence here
well this is not new anthony during the
uh summer we were concerned because our
current administration was
trying to use the vaccine as a carrot
in a political year and many folks in
the public were worried that it was
being sped up too fast and actually it
backfired
so the fact that the president was
rushing uh
you know steve pond the director of the
fda today was again
a step probably in the wrong direction
and not very reassuring for americans
who are worried around the
influence of politics and vaccines
already
so doctor we have the green light from
the fda
what will a vaccination program look
like now particularly one that aims to
inoculate 20
million people by the end of december
well it's going to be very slow uh sure
i think it's a beacon of hope for sure
and a metaphor
of success in science and a way to end
the pandemic but it probably won't have
much practical
uh use in them in the beginning because
uh
again it's a numbers game healthcare
workers
and nursing home residents will be the
first in line
but even that uh wouldn't be able uh
there wouldn't be enough
vaccines to immunize all of that group
so
we're right now in the middle of a surge
and unfortunately i don't think the
vaccine will
make much of a dent in that yeah i guess
the obvious counter to the
beacon of hope that you talk about of
the vaccine
is the daily deaths in the u.s topping
out over 3 000 now
as an infectious disease specialist how
worrying
are these numbers i'm
very very worried anthony um you know it
seems heartbreaking that we have daily
records that
exceed the 9 11 death tolls
every day and i think you know it's very
very difficult to go to work every
morning
knowing that hospitals are being filled
and most concerned your icus are being
filled and on the
streets people are disillusioned because
they've been fatigued they've been doing
this for months
and their freedoms seem to be taken away
with no playgrounds
no outdoor dining those are some of the
debates that are going on right now
yeah it's easy to get the impression
that there are equal measures perhaps of
excitement
and some skepticism around the world
when it comes to the vaccine
what's the attitude there among the
american public
um like you open with anthony i think
there's some
skepticism uh and there was during the
summer for sure
around politics speeding up the science
but what i've really tried and many of
my colleagues have tried to
think about is really the bureaucracy
being sped up the red tape being
dismantled
as the part of operation wall speed but
the americans are still not
fully on board as a community in in
august
it was 50 acceptance and november was 60
percent
a little bit lower than the 70 we need
for herd immunity
dr peter hong thank you so much for your
time
thanks so much